[Music]  for years our world has been at peace  that something is coming I can feel it  dark forces are upon us  [Music]  find these beasts or whatever they are  our world is dying there is nothing to  go back to if our people are to survive  we must make a whole media whatever  happens what happens if we do not unite  our world will perish this doesn't need  to happen there is one who may help us  there is building life at war no but  with the humans help there could be  why are you here to save all people can  we trust him  they're beasts they should all be  destroyed are you sure of that  [Music]  we'll protect a key you and I inside  with a humorous against your own kind  [Music]  this is suicide we have no choice we  should attack with full force whatever  you plan to do do it  you  [Music]